[Music]
we are what up you guys it's a Thursday
back at it again again
Persian Ritchie on the scene in
spotlight how's it going if you can't
tell by this intense music we're about
to play some call of duty modern warfare
O's you already know I mean if you guys
remember when the Alpha and the beta was
out we were on it we're all over it so
much of it and now it's officially
coming out tomorrow we're lucky enough
to be able to play it just a few hours
early so let's get it poppin we're
actually you're gonna check out some
campaign today but we're not gonna go
too far in we just want to get a little
taste
keep working low preview and then one
lady have time we're gonna hop into some
ground war oh yeah or some cool lob
we're gonna check out some of the other
features for you guys you can actually
pre-order and pre download the game
right now so that when they do go live
you can jump right in I'm actually like
still down like free downloading mine so
I just have to watch Ritchie enjoy all
the fun city but I know we'll share we
share you got to get in on this gods to
gods too but for now let's let's get it
probably was hot with some campaign
what's up chat how you doing happy
Thursday alright let's go let's go by
doing a are gay means watching from
Pakistan well hey thanks for joining
I know thanks for tuning in here we go
Bob Jones back on the scene I understand
I understand thank you Maximus hello
thanks for joining us watching from
England
at least regular realism agility point
no no no what's poppin let's do this
regular mode our war is not for our
faith we fight to remove all foreign
power from our soil we are Allah Allah
we are the killers we fight without
sorrow
we wage war without sympathy
[Music]
the only way
[Applause]
that was good
knuckle three one Charlie two actual go
for actual LZ is in sight girdle rod
four three one hit man teams are locked
and loaded for assault you are green to
go Colonel we may have a problem -
lately as well there live not until I
say so
boom watch it a 3-1 how copy he plays
well then traffic general barkhov has
sent a new shipment of chlorine gas to
his Depot but his mercs are prepping to
move the Kem's endeavors extend via
convoy tonight you're still clear to
engage but live fire on Russian military
is prohibited we cannot have an
international incident
I'll be watcher handling
Wow there we go
first of all this Wow like oh yeah I
felt like I was really dropping down all
right gotta fix things real quick maybe
turn on subtitles while you're in the
menu good idea do you see it odd
subtitles I just loved me since me too I
grew up like reading them all right
let's get it pop in it looks the
cutscenes are beautiful and hello guys
we just wanted you know let you enjoy
the cutscenes and its preciousness yeah
I think we're on our way to meet a very
special someone get this this kind of
looks like the trailer the very first
trailer we saw oh if you know what I'm
getting at we sneak in everybody's
walking you're like yeah come on nobody
wanna meet him
they're onto us yeah oh wait is your
silence around okay yeah it is you're
good wait no drop him
nope okay clear I took care of it I mean
that was easy good job team
yeah I'm running with the best guys what
up Dexter hey what's for joining Dex
playing a little early today this comes
out tonight y'all checking out some
campaign might hop into some multiplayer
later yeah fire stand by for target
confirmation its Ricky the area and make
sure there's no Russian armored out
there spotter scope vehicle coming in
the main gate one in the tower army copy
check what that's the entry Oh
CNN other one vehicles on the move
movement in the rail yard that's how the
gas comes in okay there's the truck more
for baddies here or am I supposed to be
done they move on without me no baddies
Oh two more at the gate brisance call it
hmm oh wow he's gonna drop okay that
excavated quickly very much did
seriously Viktor when they were like
sneaking around I just felt the need to
whisper I don't know if I spoke too loud
it was free I'm going to pull Otto
that's actually really scary yeah we're
here just like okay I was like where'd
my friends go hey Lefty no too busy
sightseeing okay back to a single
single-shot mode just in case I thought
we were gonna go in guns a-blazing wow
this looks really nice Brandon says he's
ready for extra life I know I am like
yeah I'm so excited
yeah and Skullgirls is out on switch I
got to get that on the stream ASAP ASAP
reinforcements checking out what's going
on oh they're looking for us
Rossini key Bevers owe us boy I don't
know why this is so stressful I'm just
so excited to be back and all right me
the boys probably Meyers
[Music]
that's the homie right there this one
day it is good old Davis old faithful
Davis we didn't work yeah we do you been
coming in
laid it out three on fire man well yeah
that is rough but a matter of misery any
bubble tap oh oh another one already
smoked out don't make me do it oh it is
the squad yo get down do my dirty work
more easy these guys are not on fire
let's go I'm paid to fight men not fires
well hello your work is arrived I'm not
getting in on this action yet they're
doing great yeah it's kind of you're
like the body cam yeah you're just the
one filming the action yep I'm here for
documentation Taylor it's it is
available for pre-order and speeds down
no rage what's up Kevin hello arrow said
I can't handle this too realistic No
I know you wanna gunfire older oh wow
they're sneaking up on us
no that's why I got your back though it
got your six
leave you this is crazy I got your 12 to
12 you got me all day around the clock
got that 24/7 without backup their help
your squad man where they act
I just ran off huh huh grenade okay
let's find the squad first that's that's
one I already lost Davis I know that one
is it the multiplayer man yeah sorry I
know that was so descriptive you guys I
know what you meant
I forgot the name of it it's been too
long since the beta oh well since we're
going we're not there we go
I know right we don't need the silence
there any more going loud oh boy
to a locker this is heavy right away I
felt like everything but his head let's
go I'm no I'm gonna pronounce your name
wrong but cerumen says it's actually
going to its roots chat section where
these groups realistic representation of
war and it's weird it was the gunner or
any realistic I don't know okay why not
it's my backup
okay that's gotta love a gun that has a
93 bully friendlies here we go where are
you running to terrifying being that
guys like we're trying to make light of
it because this is actually very heavy
this is like nervous humor and wait how
many homies we have three mana five
total including me did we revive davis
davis he permadeath wait
Randolph that's anyone mmm I don't
remember him from earlier oh no oh are
we about to gas them let's do this rip
the cheese
we've been playing so many spooky games
yeah yeah not another flash that's the
perfect setup for a jump scare the
second turn on the flashlight
something's in the door he was around
there but I think he's just running for
it now oh oh yeah me first okay we're uh
we got plot armor we do and regenerative
regenerative health good thank you
the stakes in a good way like I'm on you
know I'm on edge here still here okay
good friendly oh no oh just in time
thanks homie yeah okay little little
marker here interesting they're like you
need help yeah we can tell powers back
on let me get that night-vision goggles
though this is what we're here for
put a little chapstick on it oh I think
I like that uh dry out here on the field
okay friendlies Beckham get in the trunk
loser okay we just rolled up what I
don't like me I'm nervous though I don't
like this convoy
remember how Iron Man started look I
knew it get me out of here reverse I'm
not driving thank goodness
[Music]
that's me
we left you alive though
[Applause]
echo 3-1 watcher Terrace attack multiple
Marines ki-yay gasps stolen we need evac
now
Roger headed your way sit tight
we're pushing to you for best exfil
watch you're out did any of the homing
separation is now compartmentalized so
what the hell does that mean it means
you no longer have clearance colonel
those are my Marines we need a QRF in
there right now it's not advisable and
that is not your car colonel last well
general my man Norris give us a minute
yes ma'am we've got a situation the
Kremlin has suspended all deconfliction
channels the 6th fleet is pushing into
the Black Sea and chemical weapons are
now in the wild your fingerprints are
all over this last well fix it general
right now intelligence is our best
weapon we've tried intelligence get me a
better weapon
John as well where are you
Oh keep on I've got a problem
Boston's what travels fast chemical
weapons have fallen into terrorist hands
they could be anywhere Paris New York
what can you breathe it we just did
we have snipers in position negative
sergeant not on journey along the public
terrorists know that too sir yeah
crystal now looks like we're on our own
lads
oh that was a nice transition here we
are in London a film I like that
sergeant what's up white van
what was in view that stem Sabre -
rayvin white van multiple military age
males weapons visible moving to
intercept that wasn't obvious at all you
all the stop traffic oh my god
oh you're on your way Oh smells good I
gotta do to get ya
Aoyama surely you can't stand
this is tough I can't tell it was like
friendly right away
[Music]
definitely not ready got what roof that
is
Oh
Oh Oh honestly that's probably you're
like one of the really tough things
about being a situation leader was
accidentally shooting your civilian yep
Oh worst feeling
keep it
that's not fair we need the plotter ever
be his did you find their name would pop
up someone else cut me nice this cop
down here you gotta watch our back man
we are putting on ps4 currently for
those of you asking
hmm all right
oh man someone driving up Matty here Sam
so Paul I think they're bright goodness
whoa building offices down
hey Morgan he's asking if we're gonna
play to be two again like in the beta
we're gonna play a bit of this campaign
and then hop over to either multiplayer
go out to check out some other features
so yes stick around stick around we're
not gonna play to too much of the
campaign we're gonna play probably up
until a certain point you try to check
out some other game good aim
man only the best price always coming
through the slush
Oh Moses said I'm from central London
and they got it - it's here I'm glad
they actually went to London to get the
details right that's cool that's nice
yeah half excuse me I'm still on edge
you're holding it down you're doing
great
we see a chat now hold it down
that's
all stations norm is clear oh good like
you expect the heroics you know to kind
of just handle that situation that was
that was I mean I guess it was her ogen
away saved everybody else yeah it's like
I want to see my kids come on
beside lives today sergeant this
shouldn't have happened in the first
place sir
they said it's in how fast so everyone
can just keep pretending with our war
you're like the [ __ ] century that is
why if we got our hands tied let's just
take the bloody gloves off and fight sir
cool
we don't stand a chance in hell with
these rules of engagement captain they
can't tell us where they can tell us
when don't tell us out my member
tracking that several weeks you were the
actual inside on this quite this huh
okay
Alcatel is claiming responsibility
extent alex is on the ground they're
looking for the stolen Kemp's you only
made the liberation force on his side so
I have him comes out to sea on you know
commander Kareem blue Quentin use my
name or don't kill him what is your
message from Captain Price made a
Corrine call me Alex
I'm listening Alex this is classified
hell no one are them jaws well helical
48 hours ago terrorists or shipment of
Russian gas only I'll khattala would do
this
Russia's make no distinction between
Alcatel on your people and I make no
distinction between al khattala and the
Russian army they're both terrorists we
would never to use these poisons helped
us track it before you before they what
take it to Europe what America we live
like this every day
commander it's time to go who's this
Alex this is my brother and my penance
are there you are CIA he works with
Captain Price then you killed Russians
yes I have friends you can help us but
your sister decides what's next of
course my sister is in command and the
Russian army is still here this
occupation must end that we can all
agree on
yes no general barkos men control the
city we are plans to change that we have
no missiles but we have our ways
if you stay we can help you but if you
stay you find
we go on our toe probably our sixth an
annex follow me
[Music]
making allies ah yeah these tunnels are
our lifeline we have Intel Russian troop
commanders are in town today
push them let's start we must hold
nothing back too far on that path and we
lose ourselves get set for the airbase
attack BC Alex take those charges c4
with remote detonator Thanks watch my
sister good luck you two
thank at him yeah good Alex you got it
civilian disguise Thanks
what up Chad
trying to keep it pretty low-key there's
a lot of stories going on but thank you
all for being here pathetic what's the
report Russians are just outside if they
see your weapons they will shoot what
happens our plan fails before it starts
it's gone I'm a civilian I guess it
makes sense the last mission was like
fallout
yeah I already lost there I looked away
for a second I just wanted to see what
was going on I'm a suspicious civilian
already Chemical we are using a ps4 pro
for this paper oh my controllers gotta
go work I'm working I'm a civilian
the dog was growling at me I got to pick
something up oh yeah you right yeah yeah
I'm working see dogs work simulator now
don't bark at me I'm working and even
the dog was like it's a work
I think you're gonna use that as a
weapon Oh God she came through
tag-teaming he was beating her up
because I was like carrying that thing
around
no need a suppressor this one's empty
[Music]
someone had our idea yeah that's my oil
filter it's like think folded paper
should do something yeah I've seen that
option if you go do it
that was convenient though that it fits
perfectly just the rights smite model
alright so we sneaking up on them you
No Oh nicely done
clear clear nummies already walking I'm
feeling of crouching explosives gotta
sacrifice will not be in vain
oh yeah I'll take that yeah sure for
sure I've begun we're going back outside
yeah you always forget I think like
because of FPS games how much you're
done and he's out and about he's like
this no she's just gonna
Oh kill all the alright
Oh nerves of steel first you're just
feel yeah they made you look at your
restraint you have to have to like not
just go guns blazing anthracene
helicopter yeah we take them out from
the paper come running
[Applause]
I have to be super casual okay helpful
marker I've got a site mm-hmm that helps
I did feel like the oil can was in the
way a little bit
oh I forgot
yeah already all right I'm just gonna
walk by him and see if they stop me oh
yeah I got it I'm working see you guys
see you guys hello hello
that's on the entry you walked into the
right place throwing I'm working again
I planned tacticals like he won you
switching up my button
Brandon asks if we have to have internet
to play the campaign we're hooked up to
the minute I don't I can't answer that
because I don't know at this point I
would assume know what she say take the
stairs
yeah use the stairs Oh smooth you got
cat-like reflexes yeah love that line
okay
George said this will make one hell of a
distraction
keep working on the way I already
brought it up here why would I need to
take it down I'm working get a new block
guys all right where was the other one
yeah somewhere over there i saw a ladder
right there but i don't know if that's
the right way if there's more blocks on
that sign I'm so sorry I'm so sorry oh I
can run with this oh cool
chemical the the full review should be
up soon we have I believe the review in
progress but today is tonight is launch
day so it should be it very soon not
tonight then tomorrow or sometime very
soon nice reach to check 20 so now I can
die if I if I do it's not a big deal I
gotta deliver the center block to your
chopper oh oh he's messing with you
laughs yeah okay
oh well I'm just gonna smoke you guys
yeah we'll see who's I want to see me
[Music]
Edward Clayton thanks for joining us
yeah we're gonna play the crap out of
this campaign - on our own we can only
we can play a little bit today but Oh
Gustavo hey thanks for joining us all
the way from Brazil
George's DC says yeah you need internet
to update for a patch so you can play
solo online yeah we did have a patch
appreciate it DC all right let's blow
them up we got it
casual I know
[Applause]
[Music]
boy says hello from canada in hot Oh Oh
Nate definitely saw me okay
this lady is on it I know you're fun
follow your lead anything you say Farrah
we thought you'd wait what'd she say
except that far
she okay Oh God she said see ya what
would I do without her what I'm dead
oh you gotta blend in oh yeah sing with
the afterlife
oh he's kicking us
he's kicking the body
[Music]
I like the heartbeat did your controller
beat no 62q we get early access so we
can review the game okay he's swift I
know before I was even I was still
laying on the ground
our plan is all going according to blend
MIDI song asks how's the game so far so
far pretty impactful yes definitely it's
been a long time since a game actually
made me like physically feel a certain
way like my stomach was feeling so weird
after I watched him like hang those
people you lost good people today what
is the cost of this water now let's take
particles air base so that deaths are
nothing bang we're in for a hell of a
fight so what are they idea has a plan
you did it all right completely it's
your turn I actually like the sneaky
mode Oh cutscene
you're in my house
I set up on the edge of my crawlspace
keep those [ __ ] dogs in check friends
close enemies closer
I told you we have always no grenades so
we improvise not burn if I kiss water
sticks and stones city we set up an army
acid the Russians only understand
violence so I showed them violence
Barkov has an air force so we have one -
mm-hmm oh oh yes commander
let's fly here we go
amen
terrifying yeah there's a lot of them
yeah seeing them all together and
knowing they're like lethal and dangers
yeah fire the cannon she's going in loud
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
good-looking like me over there yeah
[Music]
nice and now we fly first quad
you know it's fast that little thing
I was right onto the open mic this is
water reaching for a second I thought
they were friendly
yeah going
oops oh wow sorry no I think it would
have lost if I did that or you know how
to restart
they're scared to bring their choppers
out friends oh well not friendly okay
more RC planes coming up oh yeah I like
that they give you a little animation
yeah like you did it right
that guy was way too close for comfort
oh boy
well there's another cheap catch flight
real quick yeah I'm gonna hide over here
is that cheap there's one I don't know
if there was anyone around but yeah
whatever
cause mayhem absolutely hate down here
what's up there I'm in the wrong area
building through the wall through the
door okay
I'm so hurt I got my multiplayer mode on
would you like to try crazy you know
what because he blew up that Jeep
earlier that's why another verb yeah
they're upset now finally the car
doesn't explode like it is in Hollywood
hey I either come out of everywhere I
know Naomi
that sniper's nest wherever you want
there you go there's a bunch of them
okay
like I could just fly planes all day if
you want to switch it to tactical go
ahead and I'll talk that's your style
I don't know anybody was over there I
thought then someone was hiding behind
that corner I just saw people walking
and saying I got scared
we're winning here it's like their
armory building at the white roof
you've got to project
yeah
Oh ting Oh God I got we're flying Omar
says this game looks a lot better and
Avalanna says damn this game is amazing
so far we're having a lot of fun with it
ah like great ah arrow says this is a
true battlefield we've been waiting for
I've been hearing converse very strong
comparisons okay oh no no I don't mean
Khan the true battlefield everyone the
way vex and the chess is freeloading now
going down we'll see you on the other
side yeah
I physically backed up I know okay okay
that's good that means
I should Adam ask this game changed for
better or worse right now I'm saying for
better it's a little too early to tell
but we're having a great time and thank
you for tuning in hopefully you like
what you see here it's been crazy we're
also playing some scary games later than
you guys that's right these are horror
continues run day for it wait
hamstring I noticed that too he says
finally they added bullet physics and
not just a hit skin although yeah kind
of felt like I was like just winging it
you know it didn't really do you feel
that really locked on enemies like it
used to
no no really yeah really stick on
beam Jesus r.i.p chopper from yeah that
was good kill earlier oh I heard like
the anger in that melee from alright you
got help from your friends you got this
like women really are
- big nap big area
oh you're so mad you swinging I know
doing great dubbing wiping them out
lazy ass what are ya what game what I
need to play before hand to understand
this storyline you know what nope first
start yeah main characters they
described it like how the developers of
the game described it like how when a
new director makes a new line of Batman
movies with a new actor instead like
same character different storyline
different directions so you don't have
to play anything Modern Warfare game you
should because the characters are great
but but you don't need to if you want to
follow the story you can just pop this
in and start oh you did okay cuz like he
ran in front of me so you like locked in
for a second make sure that little sign
is so helpful we didn't have one for
ever actually pick this up off somebody
yeah gray moving in huh I'm waiting for
someone to yell clear
blank blank triple kill oh just kidding
Oh your hops where is it
yeah what's ok it was a raga name I
think we're getting closer
I like that enthusiasm though it sounded
like you did something like from above
well me up man help me Onix okay Oh like
give me the command
Laer oh yeah okay yeah load of frags
Lascar hey all the school play it was
locked in the beta I wanted to play I
wanted to use the scar so much I know
you do good name
Oh Oh I was a big one Oh the Jeep in
front of the exploding ear supports you
just in time Dean says a nice drop shot
queen of drop shot right here man well
you got a juggernaut oh you got this
yeah these look like the bad guys we're
in the hangar behind
it is a major achievement
oh okay good we're in the hangar
everyone out here is fair game oh dude
sorry manners and Lincoln
here
Connor says I'm here for princesses of
weight right right so will we Alexson
commander Koreans forces a destroyed
general bar cops forward operations base
temporarily limiting Russian air
capability owner 16 we need to move fast
sergeant Garrick thanks to your Intel we
tracked the our qatar so responsible for
the piccadilly attack to a townhouse in
North London three SAS teams will get
inside and connected dots if the wolf is
in possession of the stolen Russian gas
in Ezek Stan we need to find him
be advised there may be non-combatants
on target
thank you shots oh boy oh it's civilians
man do a loading theme joking around
boys
what up guys from Algeria by the way hey
thanks for tuning in
thank you chat wow this looks really
nice oh here's your captain price we're
never working right here with you
we what city were
I miss it I'm probably talking just
wanted to see if it said it here nope
doesn't say
what how'd they get in there already and
I needed to use a ladder okay
just keeping her quiet but this
operation failed your dead brothers make
sure that we double the body count it's
all over the flip mentality that's the
point this is the United Kingdom do you
think anyone walks around worrying that
they're gonna get blown up well now they
do Alcala is a household [ __ ] name oh
god I need to coordinate with the other
groups Paris Moscow Munich and the Yanks
soon oh my god I think I'm free to do
this how's that tea oh you got a
friendly yeah she was the one to secure
that was so like Irina I know it wasn't
a battlefield or anything it was like
someone's house imagine conversating for
that long and there's like six freaking
soldiers in your house yeah fully armed
Oh going dark
they know we're here
the night vision Oh third floor here we
go Thomas ed be very very quiet
okay look around yeah it's pretty secure
I think I was someone in the closet your
first look secure waiting with a shoddy
yeah he's unloaded hmm it's pretty
intense if you want I know it is intense
it's fine okay I wouldn't want to share
this cuz this is this is crazy
Irie [ __ ] like literally here's our
squad
it's like synchronized swimming I know
Dean chemical we were like do we really
have to do that that lady she didn't
pick up that gun it would have been safe
I know
oh that room to your right I think the
couch Oh sneaky you can't aim down
sights I'll ring oh oh no no it's fine I
knew that I knew that we are playing on
the ps4 pro right now sergeant Williams
goodbye man out play there were three
people I got played I think all right
this time
you got no sergeant willings you should
let me go Eddie
Oh clear the way sorry Bryce there's
three bedroom clear okay stupid guy man
couch
yeah all right there
oh you gotta be real close this looks
like the top
Oh chemicals I really don't want to
shoot her
oh and she has a baby come on dude hey
man I saw you get out here bro I'd
rather pick up the baby than an a here
you go good
[Music]
we were copy boys yeah they said that
right before we got in here maybe that
wasn't the person we were looking for
feels bad man [ __ ] detonator
she was going for bloody debt and they
offered good job we dropped it in we
made the right call sir guess we just
got a trust price the townhouse was a
gold mine
looks like we found the wolf
communications from the laptop were
tracked to Roma's a hospital in Isaac's
dam where they are potala leaders
believed to be holed up forest forces
will track terror activity at the
hospital while the Marine ground force
can be mobilized to advance on the
complex echo 3-1 will capture the wolf
for interrogation about the stolen
Russian gas
yeah mocchi habanero should be zero my
soldiers confirm that the hospital is
under siege and capella has taken
civilians as human shields they're
protecting someone or something
tomorrow we find out all fear sister
Hadid is my best sniper you can rely on
him and all my fighters worries about
the pound of flesh let me charge on this
I told you we would help you when you
keeping your word I don't do this to
keep my word the invaders of my country
have no regard for human life the gas
kills all things even food and our
Gardens if you use these tactics you are
my enemy no exceptions none al capella
has given my people a bad name and we
have paid dearly for their crimes I want
to see that were punished
I'll make sure you're at the Embassy for
the handoff the price
and you but will you go and this is over
wherever they send me you don't choose
not exactly dressed up tomorrow's a big
day
what about you and your man we'll be
here until sunrise
I'll cover the open corner
the hospital is at the end of the road
half a klick I'll be huffing it with the
Marines echo 3-1 sergeant Griggs all day
tell me Alex no locals on this one I
might call you Kareem all day
nice work in the Russians we shared
friends and enemies it's folly all right
you guys so we have like 15 minutes less
of streams I think maybe we should try
to hop into a multiplayer let's do it
yeah we don't wanna go too far into the
campaign for those of you who want to
play it yourselves but we did want to
check it out a little bit very
interesting good storytelling so far in
terms of like making me feel like I'm
really there it's like kind of weird
yeah I agree it's kind of unsettling but
like that you know you're in so much
control of like these kind of dark
situations yeah like I I came to I you
know I wanted to expect that of course
but like it's a seeing it is one thing
playing it is another yeah let's get
some multiplayer action in just for the
last 15 minutes hope you guys enjoyed
what you saw of the campaign so far
obviously tons more a part of the
campaign you guys check out yeah we'll
leave that to y'all what do you want to
play um I feel like everyone in the chat
has been like super interested in ground
without a line earlier it's like play
some ground war so maybe some of that
what do you guys think what do you want
to see yeah is for 15 minutes we might
be able to get one to two matches out
it's ground more Alex I don't see you
sure I truly I'm looking at it huh maybe
not at the moment until actual launch
yeah that's true that's true
all right so we'll do maybe just a quick
play or something
yeah let's see what it will shuffle it
up here hey Nate's what up he and busy
how's it going whoo yeah Lexi Hey
yeah chemical says the campaign viewing
was stressful yeah glad you feel the
same way it was a little stressful but
yeah we were happy to like bring it to
you guys we all kind of just experience
that together a little heavy I mean I
think it definitely speaks volumes to
the fact that you know they were able to
like evoke that emotion out of this
little domination Oh a new map we
haven't tried this wasn't in the beta
nice right good luck Richie Godspeed
here we go my first uh multiplayer
experience full release I got nothing
unlocked you guys this stinks but the
FAMAS what do they call it it's the five
five six let's go nice and sunny
well oh no oh man the subtitles in stone
oh yeah no in classic ecology D fashion
entering the game late and in a huge
deficit oh yeah you're right I kind of
walked into this one oh no I don't have
my rocket class or anything we're gonna
get mowed down is our door here it's
like plastic call of duty struggle life
you start up with just the bare bones
classes yep oh that guy's a rocket okay
they took the helicopter yeah let's go
try to get be back maybe I flanked for a
how do you play Rossetti it really
depends like your it's the end here but
I usually just try to get around to the
other side forced like a Sun switch of
some sorts for sure yeah I've already
pinned down
Lex yes this is gifts for pro gameplay
you're seeing here friend yep yep but
also available on Xbox and PC
and there's crossplane so that's gonna
yeah okay a few ways to get over there
good good good oh no I wonder what the
preferred platform will be for
tournament yeah good question huh
since I'm sure for tournaments they
might have to narrow it down do you
think or do they have to like oh it's
okay that they switch it up and that's
cross play I guess the smartest thing
would be to do it on PC because you can
also have like Xbox and ps4 controllers
that'll work on PC so if people are
console players they can at least still
use their controller not be like you
Jill there I am look right on the bottom
one kill well it's okay that we joined
link is in oh never mind I was gonna say
you're gonna be in the lobby and then
you can actually play from the beginning
but they 100% took you back yeah mm-hmm
new operators it's searching for a game
I believe
yeah searching up top hey here we go not
all of these were unlocked actually only
a few of them were when the beta was
going around
I mean it's not outside the realm of
possibility to you know do well against
PC players obviously it's gonna be
extremely difficult but I mean if you
look at some of the other eSports FPS
games right now like apex there's some
controller players even some old like
Halo pros jumping into the apex
tournament scene using controllers on PC
like snipe down nice wig also use a
controller player not out of the
question yeah it's gonna be extremely
good ok here we go another new map what
kind of motor
I missed it we're playing a team
deathmatch ok got my ghost mode on
wish me luck guys hmm
don't want to go too out in the open
yeah okay got the nice edge over here
whoa friendly even said he's on with you
actually saw a discussion recently we're
like PC players were complaining about
the amesys that's you know that comes
with using the controller yeah feels
like once you connect the controller it
automatically does it for you and PC
players are actually complaining about
that and I was like dude you're using a
mouse and a keyboard right the face this
map is so it's nice so far
hey Lex was asking if we can have our
nicknames on the stream yeah we do only
show you like at the beginning and when
we're doing the intros and outros but a
time prayers' oh this is Richie hey yeah
thank you guys for joining us and uh
hope you like watching people getting
killed a lot I'm dying here we're all
learning but just get my feet wet you
know it's like be negative one right
tomorrow you do when the early hours
here I don't the claim or my class is
just not yeah you you're totally still
in beta mindset right now when you
actually had equipment options of good
yep a lot going on over there just want
to be on the lookout okay oh I haven't
changed my buttons either that's okay
enough excuses get good yeah it's gotta
get good
well these red skulls I know it's good
mmm-hmm I know I've cover have friends
over here um for JP mentioning like you
can play against mouse mouse and
keyboard only or play against pad versus
pad only you actually can change the
setting to your preference so you can
set it up to where you get matched with
anybody regardless of what equipment
they're using sure you can set it to
where you're only playing against you
know if you're on ps4 only pas players
our Xbox only Xbox players so they give
you some options of preferences what you
want to go with yeah you can customize
that it's really nice yeah I know during
the beta I did play against people who
are using mouse and keyboards and yeah
they show you they show you straight up
in the lobby okay this is their spawn it
looks like or you respond if they
switched Chris Stephenson said Cod
Mobile rules all right when that's no I
did not have high expectations of any
means or you know really give it that
much thought and then I tried it and I
could really really liked it so that's
funny to this guy really was campanella
in here oh yeah maybe not yeah what the
hell maybe he bounced it was all beat
right behind me
[Applause]
I'm hearing it but I'm not seen it come
on Oh had that perk on oh oh the one
that shows the footsteps yeah
sorry bro a guy no rocket how many hours
until a release I guess that really
depends on where you are yeah the
website I think yeah the Twitter the
Activision or the call of duty Twitter
accounts to tell you based on your time
zone so I would hit them up check it out
it helped me this morning I was like ok
9 p.m. for me oh it's ok a good class
right I'm ghosting oh I think yeah they
do have some sort of kill streak UAVs
perforator I think personal Raiders cool
but doesn't it hover over you kind of
yeah I never used it in there in the
beta because I used the regular UAV
instead mm-hmm cuz that one helped us
like everybody oh there was some action
[Music]
that's a close game is it oh yeah
another one is the UI colorblind
friendly menu options but I've noticed
more and more games recently and being
more friendly to that so I like playing
games with max cuz I always get to see
how it looks oh he uses that yeah I
always think it's the coolest thing he
just laughs I hear noise noise for my
friends wait what we changed it okay
right got a cluster strike I do
oh let's go oh it's one of these oh why
did it whatever at least y'all get to
see it yeah Wow oh no maybe someone
already
no one did it's all good me we used it
you guys
Nova Deathstar this game is not
officially out we do have a little bit
of early access here but it is up
tomorrow so you don't have to wait long
and if you preorder you can free
download someone's over there someone
else was no he got me I got killed by a
mate it's always a moment that you like
stop or look away for me it's that
moment when you just the campaign was
really cool Aaron we played a bit of it
didn't want to get too far in wanted to
avoid like any major spoilers plus we
only had a few minutes left in the
stream so we hop with a multiplayer
match
you guys both spook to each other yeah
he's on fire no but death star how are
you on it that's classified brother we
got me yeah if you already pre-ordered
it make sure you pre download it too so
you don't have to wait a long time so
like actually play once yeah you can pre
download it and then it ceases you it's
like you can play this game in it stays
on your ps4 dashboard thing hmm
pers you wanna play I mean yeah here let
me hide ya Mystics runner on
for a little bit got this you changed my
yeah I'm gonna take all this time and
then it's gonna be like game over oh you
as he was what's it called mount mount
it up yeah come on little Mike I
actually canceled my reload yeah yeah
our team is we're down uh yeah there is
no path over here noise those new math
problems yeah exactly
together oh you would do a sprinting
again
Oh hot over here the blog is hot oh no
there were two oh that's right a little
staircase yeah I thought it was a long
note it next time Oh sneaky he has the
same post by camping out little Mikey
again each time limit we didn't even
like yeah they couldn't even kill us in
an efficient timely mattered okay
alright cool whoa well at least we got
wonderful dang it was yeah he just came
off that sick jumping all right you guys
well we got one good match in there one
full multiplayer match we played some
campaign and that it was gonna be it for
us too well not for the whole day just
for right now just for call of duty it's
gonna be out tomorrow you guys ps4 xbox
pc make sure you hop on it is your
flavor of game
if your flavor is spooky games though
come back later 2 p.m. in a couple of
hours because we're gonna be playing
spooky games this is a part of our eight
days of horror marathon and Halloween so
we're actually playing Resident Evil 7
at - Richie's played it and he just
wants to see me get scared it's gonna
happen so let's do it hope to see you
guys at 2 p.m. and thanks for joining us
today see you later peace now bye
you